avec nous ce soir
hélène gagné gestionnaire de
portefeuille chez gestion privée gagné
johnston bonsoir hélène gagné mensonges
et rades merci d'être d'être avec nous
pour répondre à quelques questions parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de questions sur
toutes sortes de sujets notamment sur
les finances personnelles et toute la
volatilité des marchés
donc j'y vais tout de suite on saute
dans le bain aussi devrais-je reporter
ma retraite
et là je parle pas de moi là c'est
quelqu'un qui nous a posé cette question
de vrais jeux reporter ma retraite mais
en fait je dirais ça va dépendre de la
durée de la crise et de l'impact que
c'est un gros sous les pertes sur le
portefeuille de l'individu c'est sûr que
de prendre la décision de reporter sa
retraite ça va ça va permettre à la
personne d'abord de réduire la pression
sur le portefeuille mais sur elle même
mais aussi parce que ça lui donnerait le
temps au portefeuille de récupérer et
par la spa de la personne ne fera pas de
décaissement savait qu'à qu'on prend sa
retraite puis que ça survient à un
moment où on traverse une séquence
négative de rama c'est affecte la durée
de vie du portefeuille alors une fois
que la situation va avancer un petit peu
plus
il serait approprié s'asseoir avec le
planificateur financier d'actualiser son
plan ouais effectivement c'est important
puis c'est sûr que beaucoup de
volatilité sa remontée cette semaine les
marchés boursiers on peut pas suffire à
tuer ça peut bouger pas mal je vais avec
une autre question hélène tout de suite
je retire des sommes chaque mois de mon
portefeuille dans les circonstances
actuelles de mouvements des marchés
est-ce que je devrais continuer mais
idéalement c'est de cesser les retraits
s'il a perçu la personne de cette
possibilité le sel peut s'organiser
autrement ou à tout le moins les
diminuer surtout si la personne fait
lire très directement par exemple d'un
forme d'actions parce qu on essaie de ne
pas vendre d'actions d'un contexte
actuel si la personne a bien planifié
qu'elle a par exemple de liquidités dans
un compte à intérêt élevé d oublier
a sion de qualité qui viennent à
échéance à court terme mais elle peut
continuer à faire s'est retiré en
utilisant ce bassin de de liquidités là
mais si jamais elle épuisée où elle
était proche dé puiser cette réserve de
liquidité lot il y aurait lieu de revoir
le plan parfait
autre question n'aurait air sont avec la
ftq la csn
devrions-nous les transférer vers notre
caisse desjardins avant juin nous
pensions les utiliser après l'âge de 65
ans bon de ce que je comprends de cette
question c'est que les détenteurs des
actions de ftq et csn sont âgées de
moins de 65 ans ce que l'on ne sait pas
si si ils ont perdu leur emploi s'ils
sont déjà retraités pour moi les actions
des parts des travaillants sont évalués
deux fois par an dans le cadre des q7
évaluer le 30 juin et le 31 décembre
dans la le coach fonds d'actions de csn
c'est les actions sont évaluées 31000 39
ans pour les personnes qui à 65 ans et
plus
y'a pas de soucis pour transférer les
parts au moment où il veut puis da ce
colosse la personne décider de les
transférer avant la prochaine évaluation
elle n'aurait pas d'inquiétude
maintenant pour les gens qui n'ont pas
65 ans car il ya des règles
particulières s'impliquent et selon la
question des téléspectateurs ne comprend
que le il désire transférer vers la
caisse populaire donc qui disait
récemment procédé à un retrait pour
utiliser sont pour l'heure pour leurs
besoins immédiats alors les fourni les
fonds des travailleurs qui vont
permettre à chaque certains
transfèrements 65 notamment dans le code
une perte d'emploi ou pour un
travailleur autonome la perte d'un
contrat unique une réduction et volant
ça peut s'appliquer à beaucoup de
personnes présentes
non on y va avec une une nuance
rapidement ingérable si vous permettez
dans ce contexte exceptionnel le conseil
d'administration
de ces fonds de travailleurs peut
décider de modifier l'évaluation des bas
si ça se produit ce qu'un processus qui
est très encadrée si cela se produisait
ils doivent en informer les détenteurs
d'actions par le biais d'un communiqué
de presse et les gens ont 30 jours après
l'émission du communiqué pour acheter le
gouvernement fédéral a annoncé une
réduction de 25% pour le retrait minimum
exigé des fers à quel moment ce sens en
vigueur bon alors on ne connaît pas
encore les modalités
ça a été annoncé et les institutions
financières
évidemment ne sont pas prêtes à réduire
les retraites médiatement ou a redéposé
les sommes excédentaires qui aurait été
aurait été retirée rapidement en 2008 à
la fin 2008 dans la crise financière le
gouvernement fédéral avait annoncé une
mesure semblable et à ce moment là la
façon dont ça fonctionne c'est que les
gens ont pu remettre le 25 % question
dans leur sphère donc déposé dans leur
faire ce qui est inhabituel dans les 60
premiers jours de l'année qui a suivi
maintenant à la lumière de cette
expérience là est ce que les modalités
son lit mais ça reste à confirmer mais
si la personne
la personne qui désire procéder à ces
remboursements l'éventuelle la main
qu'elle garde les liquidités de côté
évidemment je pense que ça répond à la
prochaine question qu'arrive-t-il aux
dépôts de fer qui ont déjà été payées
aux retraités dans le cadre des retraits
obligatoires
on verra ce qui va se passer si on se
fie à ce qui s'est passé
justement dans le passé j'ai tout de
suite avec l'autre question dans ce que
si mon conjoint et moi sommes retraités
nous vivons offert nous n'avons aucune
aide du fédéral étant donné que nous ne
sommes plus les travailleurs qu'est ce
que les gouvernements prévoient faire
pour nous alors à carla et on ignore
l'âge décès jeanne donc on ne sait pas
s'ils touchent des prestations de régie
des rentes ou la pensée en sécurité de
vieillesse
présentement je voulais à l'exception de
la réduction sur votre fr de 25% qui a
été annoncé il semble pas y avoir
beaucoup de mesures spécifiques pour
leur situation
c'est sûr que dit
des mesures d'assouplissement par
exemple le paiement qui est un peu
retardé pour les impôts des taxes
municipales
hydro québec aussi donc les stratégies
pour ces gens lors c'est d'abord de
revoir leur budget pour réduire les
dépenses autant passer de réduire le
retrait du fer si c'est possible ou même
de le retarder plus tard dans l'année
si le marché romand qui pourra en
profiter
une autre chose qui peuvent considérer
aussi de vérifier quel est le taux
d'impôt à la source sur leur retrait il
ya peut-être des possibilités de l'est
de réduire certes de l'os à l'ific a
aussi qu'ils aient des démontages d'un
pouvoir payer l'année suivant et puis il
faut décaisser de la partie sécuritaire
ce portefeuille comme je dis un peu plus
tôt une autre côté des actions on voit
ici leur jeu le permet il est vraiment
vernie peut-être considéré hélène c'est
la magie de ce qu'un plagiat c'est de
vous couper mais je veux savoir une
réponse oui ou non est ce que c'est un
bon moment pour investir
c'est trop tôt ou si vous voulez faire
allez-y paris tap à tous les mois ok pas
fait par étapes
merci beaucoup hélène gagné c'était très
intéressant encore ce soir à la presse à
bercy